What is so important, is that from,
I think the private sector has a role to be looking for more
businesses,
at least as an investor to be looking for more businesses that are still using
technology, still software based or technology based businesses,
but that are scaling employment for empathetic or human type work.
Um, and there's a bunch of new ones that I hope will be created.
We backed a company called Papa. That's doing very well.
That's it's grandkids on demand, which sounds silly,
but with 10,000 boomers retiring every day,
and definitely not anywhere close to 10,000, like home health workers,
starting jobs every day,
there's a huge need for empathetic people who can spend an hour
at a time with the elderly,
doing everything from like helping them with their Netflix,
to just talking to them, right.
Loneliness is actually an epidemic and has health consequences.
And so health plans are more motivated than ever to bring on these Papa pals
to take time, to be with their patients,
to be with their members because it improves their health outcomes because it
actually helps bring more sort of data and feedback into the whole
conversation because they actually can say like, Oh,
you need to go to the doctor. Like, let me, let me drive you to the doctor.
Let me go help you pick up your medicine like that.
That solves a problem that we're not,
I personally don't think we're ever going to have empathetic,
like truly empathetic robots. Um,
Elan begs to differ on that one.
But for the time being there are still these jobs that are the domain of humans
and should always be, uh, that are variable.
We're going to have, we have to delve into this alikes as humanity, as medicine,
humanity, as elder care,
like that's staggeringly simple and
profound and important at the same time. Uh, like I, I want to hear more.
It's called pop-up APA.
Yay. Um, and join papa.com is the website. Um, but what the CEO,
so what Andrew realized was this didn't exist as a
type of work because it's not, these are not medical professionals.
These are not home healthcare AIDS who are doing drug administration and stuff.
These are just empathetic kind people.
And they go through diligence screening process.
A lot of them are actually sort of college age students
who are in or learning medical professions.
So if you are in nursing school,
you want to make some good money on the side.
Instead of say working that retail job at comp USA,
you're a Papa pal because it's actually helping you develop the skills that are
valuable for your career.
That only a human can go and it's work where you come home every day,
feeling amazing. Like I also,
I also worked at a pizza hut for a number of years as a cook and a waiter.
Like if I could have been a Papa pal instead of a pizza hut,
cook, I, sorry, pizza. I would have taken that 10 times over.
Like I have to smell like pizza every day. At the end of work,
I could smell like lavender or whatever the folks is home smell like
and actually feel really good about the work I did and make, make good money.
I think, you know, his instinct and it's only this,
company's only a couple of years old.
It's made great progress so far tracking very well.
And I think it is only a matter of time or in the next five years,
this will be a career option because the market will have properly valued this
time.
And the experts we're great at it that you can make a living as a Papa
pal. Like this will be a profession and it will be something that like,
as a society will already value because my God,
we don't do enough to support our seniors. So like it's easy.
Society is all very quick to be like, that's a good idea. And,
and then once the dollars follow that where, you know, off far too often,
we have a lot of these jobs where everyone agrees.
It's a great idea and really important, but the dollars aren't there,
he's going to make the dollars get there.
And an entirely new class of people who, you know,
are growing up and we can talk about higher education.
Maybe they decide that higher ed and the costs of incurring that,
assuming that doesn't change the debt that they would take on, isn't worth it.
And really what they want to do is just help people and help the elderly.
And this is a path to actually make a great living. Awesome.
Everyone knows that there, that we have an aging population and like you said,
like 10,000 people a day. Um, and, um, in,
in some idyllic vision that, uh, many of these older Americans are in pleasant,
community, retirement facilities and homes,
and they have grandkids that visit them on the regular and all this stuff.
But now when COVID, uh, even if you had grandkids who wanted to visit you,
they're not going to, uh, so then the need for companionship,
um, and help and, uh, you know, human company and contact, uh,
agree that it has a very, um, crucial health benefits.
So even on that level, you'd be like, well,
there's probably going to help maintain this. Person's, um,
like functionality for extra X number of years.
So under the Papa model who is paying.
So you can do direct. So I like your,
I could sign up and just do sort of the direct to consumer. It's like, Hey,
come, come visit my grandpa every week. And it's just build no problem.
Um, but where the real growth is, is actually from health plans.
So health plans, and these are folks who are very,
very motivated to keep their patients well. Right.
And, and it turns out for them,
it's invaluable because the more of this companionship they can create the more
of this assistance they create the healthier, the outcomes are, right.
We're only starting to scratch the surface on loneliness as an epidemic,
but the papers are getting published. There's a real health cost.
There's a loneliness. Yeah, for sure. I think now we all got a dose of it,
right? During COVID and the lockdowns,
there are a lot of folks who are really way more empathetic with the
idea of an isolated senior than they've ever been myself included. Right.
And so it sounds like the Papa pal is meant to visit them in person. Um,
so is there a ratio where it's like 80% digital, like a, you know,
one visit a week? Like, what does that activity set look like?
So this is an example, every, okay.
If you ever a good question to ask every company next year and venture
investors are already asking this question, which is,
how did COVID affect your business and what was the,
like the there's going to be a very,
just like that case shaped recovery in the economy broadly,
there are really it's at the extremes businesses either
had five years of what was going to be steady growth and adoption
compressed into five months of rapid growth or the opposite.
Papa ended up being one of the former.
They had virtual companionship as a small part of their business starting
out, and COVID only accelerated the adoption.
So now they're, they're majority virtual.
So it started out a couple of years ago building the software so that like,
as a Papa pal, I could open my phone, have my appointments scheduled,
to hit a button. And like,
I'd see on the map where I drive to go visit their home. And that was a very,
you know, physical in person set up,
but COVID accelerated the adoption of virtual companionship.
And so that is the dominant one now. And, you know,
for a generation of boomers in particular, they're all,
everyone's arms with a smartphone now. Um, you know,
the last 10 years in particular have brought adoption to a level where yeah,
you know, a lot of folks are very comfortable with zoom and
FaceTime that we never would have expected, um, a lot faster. Um,
thanks to this sort of necessity of this and, and,
and pop has been a great beneficiary of it. And yeah,
it turns out even the virtual companionship has the same outcomes
for patients. Um, things like I,
this is something I can't, and this is another one where you,
I think I take for granted having founded Reddit,
but I can't unsee how real
relationships are, even when they are digital,
even when they are total strangers,
even when you don't even know what the person looks like,
because I've seen that happen for 15 years on a platform where all you know is a
username and the text they write.
So if that exists and it's very strong and in some cases stronger, I mean,
there are,
there are people on the internet who don't know anything about fluffy bunny, 16,
other than that's their username.
And yet they have a closer relationship with them than the people they see at
the office or normally would see at the office every day.
Well, I hope it's been established that you can build very,
very strong relationships, uh, online, digitally, uh,
in different ways. I mean, heck there's that movie, her with Joaquin Phoenix,
like falling in love with his phone,
which I did not find to be that implausible.
It was like he had it like, you know, uh, and, and so,
so to use, uh, the consumer facing, um,
model as an example, let's say that I'm a very busy parent. Um,
I'll use myself screw it personally. So like, let's say I'm a very busy parent.
I've got parents who are aging. I can just sign up. Uh, I can be like, Hey,
great news. Uh, I've got some Papa pal, like for you, and then you like pick,
pick them up so you can get it as like a gift for your aging relatives.
And then they would just have someone who could minister to their, um,
tech questions. And cause I will say as a, an adult, um,
I get tech questions randomly from my parents.
It's not the response from my step-mom about which Mac book she should buy.
And yeah, no, I, and it's, it's tough too. Cause like I want to be,
I want to be a good kid, but I'm also like just Google it. You don't know.
[Inaudible] real top of bell unit to get in there.
That helped out help us pop a pal that like that. And, and you know,
another interesting thing that I wouldn't have expected, I gave,
I gave Andrew a hard time because he had a one 800 number on his website back.
It was just starting out and we were leading that round and I was like really a
one 800 number. And he's like, you don't understand,
like this is the way to do it. Yeah. You can sign up through the website,
but you put the one in a hundred number, trust me,
because it's going to help so much with, with, um,
onboarding and he's been absolutely right. Um, so yeah,
if you wanted to schedule the one 800, the Papa Valley,
you could do it online or download the app or you could also just call one 800
number because for a lot of their customers,
that's the most comfortable way to do it. And it's that,
that little thing like my,
my naivete slash arrogance in that moment of like really a one 800 number,
that is why I love entrepreneurship because the founder,
the CEO,
he knew he had to be humble enough to
go to where his users were or to build something that people actually wanted.
And you know,
the founders who are successful are the ones who can break out of their own bias
and actually empathize. And like, so in that moment as an investor,
I was clearly not empathizing well, but, but that's one of the things that is,
um, I think so needed right now because we have so many big problems to
solve so many and the private sector can't do all of it. Let me also say,
I don't think the private sector can do all of it,
but there are areas where we need entire industries to be invented.
We need career like being a Papa pal to be invented. And,
and there's countless more because we need alternatives for
those jobs.
That are going to get largely automated. And, and I'm,
I know this is not the entire solution, but it's a big part of it. And,
and that's really the impetus behind why I do what I do now,
because I need to help. As many of those things get started as possible. To me,
the ideal vision Alexis is that, uh,
the government helps create incentives for the creation of these jobs and
industries. You know what I mean?
Cause like right now you look at it and you can find, uh,
an opportunity like Papa pal,
where there there's enough money currently heading into it where you can
actually build a business around it. Uh,
but there are other things where you look and say, Ooh, that should exist. Um,
but there aren't the monetary incentives in place right now. Uh,
and th this is where a lot of the no, um,
sustainability efforts go. It's like, well,
we all can see that we should be investing in a sustainable energy
products, but sometimes the money's not there because Hey, guess what?
Fossil fuels are really cheap right now and the rest of it.
And so like the ideal situation is the government actually helps create the
incentives so that people like you can invest in the innovators and
entrepreneurs who want to try and build these things. Um, even Papa pal.
When I think about, uh, why I was pressing on the, the, uh,
business model and the revenues were to me,
the social need for Papa pals, uh,
is sky high. And then the question is whether, uh,
the folks that need a Papa pal have a healthcare health plan provider,
that's smart enough to buy it,
have relatives that are smart enough to buy it and have the resources to do so.
Uh, you know, you can imagine a world where the government was like,
you know what, like, I'm not saying Papa pals the way, but like,
we're going to have like a, you know,
some stipend for anti loneliness measures and you can do whatever you want with
them. You can, you know, talk to friends, family,
you can like use a subscription service like this. I mean,
there is a world where we can actually start throwing, uh,
higher levels of resources at some of these problems,
but I couldn't agree with you more that it's innovators and entrepreneurs that
hopefully will, um, will give rise to the jobs we need.
Thank you for listening in. I hope you enjoyed this conversation. If you did,
please do subscribe to yang,
speaks and click on notifications so we can let you know every time we have a
new episode.